you
Oh
verbs are among those variable words we
saw in the intro to this series each
verb has a stem and a range of endings
we'll dig into the components of those
endings at the end of this video
the feature known as person gives away
the conversational distance of the actor
from the speaker I am the first person
you are the second person and somebody
else he she or it is the third person
Latin verbs had different endings for
these three persons mo
Thomas Emmet you didn't even need a
pronoun with the verb in Latin just
these endings romance verbs work the
same way
vulgar latin tanto Dantas gonta much
like Catalan canta canta canta and
Italian canta canta canta of course you
can include the subject perhaps for
emphasis ago canto two Kantas show canto
two cantos yo canto two can t certain
languages in or not far from France the
only major one being French require a
subject but this is an innovation French
result and not just salt for icing the
modern languages also developed polite
second person forms Cantus addresses you
informally but to be polite languages
like Portuguese Spanish and Italian
co-opt content other languages like
French and Romanian use plural forms for
the same purpose
first second and third person forms also
exist in the plural imam moussa amatis
amant Vulgar Latin verbs have unique
endings for these two cantamos cantatas
canton french romance
Emiliano romagnolo and a few other
languages still require pronouns
politeness matters in the plural - to
address a group of people politely some
languages use content French romich and
Romanian use the second person plural
verb to address one of you politely or a
group of you in any way can that's but
the same isn't true of Spanish can dice
which is only an informal way of saying
all of you sing bring back those nouns
from last time third person endings are
the ones to use with them singular with
singular nouns plurals with plural nouns
so aloo pucon taught or ela leu P
content or maybe with a more fitting
noun alumina can't add yellow so -
content
verbs like amis and contas have a
content part a stem and a range of
possible endings the stem doesn't stand
alone unlike in English gunt needs an
ending to be a usable word verb endings
come in pieces the first piece is the
conjugation which is the grammatical
group of verbs that ever belongs to
these come in four flavors at a II and
what was originally a nothing vowel
these are numbered first conjugation
second conjugation third and fourth the
verbs you've seen so far of are of the a
flavor the first conjugation these
vowels in each conjugation are the verbs
theme called its thematic vowel so canta
has a stem meaning sing and a thematic
ah but it's not ready yet
we need person and number endings which
you've already learned we build gun toss
or you sing
compare that to fourth conjugation theme
which is a stem with a thematic e so
Feeney's means you finish vide means c
and has a thematic a so Vives can pass
you sing got that he or she sings now
what do you think the word for she sees
was in vulgar latin
cantamos content so what we see
what about they see
if you want to cite the verb
conceptually but don't plan to name the
subject romance has an ending for that
it's the infinitive but a Ahmadi can't
add a video a fini day I know I've been
skipping that third conjugation with the
zero thematic vowel in classical and
vulgar latin these often show up with an
unstressed a like decatur unlike all the
other infinitives the emphasis is on the
stem not on the thematic vowel so it's
DJ not DJ today
this robust system gets modified in many
languages for instance Iberian languages
merge that odd third conjugation into
the second or to the fourth
the four conjugations and six
some numbers are key components of the
romance verb system will begin layering
tenses aspects and moods on to these
components